The Joe Rogan Experience we are now at a
place where we recently announced that
our second phase three study was uh
successful and was confirmatory our
first phase three study was incredibly
successful and to give you a sense of
how successful and we published this in
nature medicine
the FDA looks at statistical
significance so there's efficacy and
safety so efficacy is determined by
basically statistical significance
and you have to have 0.05 which means 1
in 20 chance that it's random that it's
not from what you think it was you know
that your intervention your experiment
said yes it's statistically significant
that means it's 1 in 20 or lower chance
that it's your finding is random and you
have to have two of those
and the and so if you have one in 20 and
then you multiply them another one in 20
it's one in four hundred chance that
that these two independent studies have
produced results that are random and
then the FDA will approve it our first
study was one in
10 000 chance that it was random it was
just incredible now how do you do that
how do you get that's great statistical
significance you get it because you have
um a big difference between the two
groups and you also have not that much
variability so what it means is the
people that got MDMA
pretty much of them got major benefits
and the people that got the therapy
without MDMA so I should say the people
got therapy with MDMA did great pretty
not very much variability it doesn't
work for everybody but we had 88 percent
responders we had 67 percent no longer
had a diagnosis of PTSD these are severe
PTSD patients that
um
at PTSD an average of 14 years one third
over 20 years and then we had
um
just another 21 had uh what's called
clinically significant response
and uh they still have PTSD but over
time they might get better if they could
have had a fourth session they might get
better so and we had a great safety
record we had nobody attempt we had
actually nobody in the MDMA Therapy
Group tried to kill themselves tried to
hurt themselves we enrolled people that
have previously attempted suicide we did
have one woman try to kill herself twice
during the study but she was in the
placebo group she got therapy without
MDMA we had another woman it was so
difficult for her to confront her trauma
that she checked herself into a hospital
to not self-harm she also was in the
placebo group so the results were
phenomenal and science the journal
science one of the most important uh
journals in the world in science at the
end of every year they publish a list of
what they think are the top 10
scientific breakthroughs of the year
and they chose our study in nature
medicine as one of the world's top 10
breakthroughs of the year it was it was
phenomenal and we had special
um
appreciation for what science was
willing to do because you talked about
beforehand about holes in the brain so
20 years before science had published
this article that they never should have
published and this was by researchers at
Johns Hopkins that had been funded by
the national and Son drug abuse and what
they claimed is
that MDMA could hurt dopamine this was a
study in primates and they said oh my
God MDMA can hurt dopamine and
it could cause Parkinson's and that this
could be a real danger now this was
around 2002 2003 and they had
um since 1985 it had all been about MDMA
supposedly hurting serotonin and causing
holes in the brains from serotonin
and we had done studies in primates
before with these same researchers where
none of the primates died from overdoses
that there didn't seem to be any
problems with dopamine
but the The Narrative of the the
anti-drug people the nationalism drug
abuse about serotonin neurotoxicity was
sort of diminishing people weren't
showing problems and so what they were
saying was well you're reducing your
cognitive reserves and so you don't show
problems now but when you get older
you're going to show problems so the
time bomb theory do they have evidence
of this no and not only do they not have
evidence but a lot of older people took
MDMA and they were fine so if they had
had this you know decline of Aging
age-related decline so it does drop your
dopamine levels right or certain levels
in a short term yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes it does but it doesn't do this kind
of damage to the brain in that way they
recover within a day or so and there's
mitigation techniques like with 5-HTP we
don't use those but people do use those
so I don't use those because we don't
think it's necessary so what we we first
proposed we in 1992 is when we got
permission for the first study with MDMA
and people had been using 5-HTP after
MDMA but there's there is a benefit to
using 5-HTP it boosts your serotonin
levels quicker correct yes yes it can be
helpful but what we do in a therapy
context so the FDA we said should we try
administering with 5-HTP or something
like that they said
um they said don't do that you know
let's do everything under observation
and see what the problems are and if you
need if you see problems then we should
figure out how to mitigate the problems
so the key thing that we do is to say to
people that when you take MDMA it's a
two-day experience it's not a one-day
experience and the second day is for
rest and for reflection and they have no
obligations no appointments nothing that
you need to do
just take the second day and and rest
and that's where people would take five
hdp if they wanted to but we don't see
this uh dip in mood
any more in the MDMA group than in the
group that gets therapy without it so
this people talk about suicide Tuesdays
or you know this this the depression
after you've used up serotonin
um but I think the rest part is part of
the therapeutic process and it so we
have never felt the need to
recommend that people do five HTTP I
don't think it's a bad idea to do I mean
if people wanted to do it it can be
helpful but we just feel that the rest
is just as helpful and it's more
therapeutic so what but they're not
mutually exclusive no no we could do
both yeah for sure for sure but but we
don't in the research we have we haven't
found the need so but what science had
um yeah so so this idea of serotonergic
neurotoxicity and holes in your brain
and Time Bomb theories just wasn't
working anymore it wasn't persuading
people wasn't persuading the FDA so Nida
funded this study uh una McCann and
George McCurdy and it was in primates
and as it turned out a bunch of the
primates died of overdoses and um and
they published the paper in science that
said that MDMA could cause Parkinson's
that could hurt dopamine
and
the editor of uh the science is
published by the American Association
for the advancement of science the the
president of that was Alan leschner he
used to be the head of Nida and he
fanned the fears of MDMA and he did that
in Congress and it was great because
then he got more money for night I got
him over a billion dollars a year so he
published a press release uh about this
article and it said that taking MDMA was
like playing Russian roulette with your
brain right so it didn't seem right this
article we we knew that we'd given MDMA
do primates for research and nobody died
of overdoses none of them did so we we
wrote a letter to the editor and um we
questioned it they didn't give it the
way people take it which is orally as
well and so we can't give it they gave
it subcutaneously so they injected it
Sub-Q and so we ended up
um forcing them in their minds to try to
replicate their results okay pause you
for a second how did these primates die
of overdoses um they would just have
like heart attacks or or something like
that
um is that common with humans no no so
so here's how this continues so so they
they also you get more neurotoxicity in
crowds for some reason when animals or
people or
uh together than when they're alone and
when the temperature is higher there's
more neurotoxicity so they tried giving
more MDMA to primates with higher
temperatures more crowded in the cages
and they couldn't replicate their
results
and they but they kept defending it in
public and finally a year later they
said that um and this was super
embarrassing they had to retract the
study because they were puzzled why they
couldn't replicate the results and so
they took some of the tissue from one of
the animals that had
overdosed and died and they discovered
that they had mistakenly given
methamphetamine instead of MDMA
and that the bottles they said that were
labeled MDMA actually had
methamphetamine in them and so these
they they got these bottles from a group
called Research Triangle Institute in
North Carolina they provide all the
schedule one drugs for all the night of
funded researchers so the Hopkins people
blame the people at Research Triangle
Institute and said they switched the
labels on the bottles the the people
from Research Triangle Institute said
they never do that they always test it
they have quality control they think
that it got switched something or other
at the site at Johns Hopkins the
National Institute of drug abuse didn't
want to find out what was going on or if
they did want to find out they never
made it public so it's never clear how
did this happen but they had to retract
this data and retract their papers and
it was um the high water mark of
neurotoxicity fears and at the same time
Peter Jennings was doing a documentary
called ecstasy rising and this was the
first documentary that really had a
bunch of people talking about the
benefits and he also talked about this
problem with the methamphetamine the
other thing about methamphetamine versus
MDMA is that you know for people that
know about Adderall and other things 10
15 milligrams is a hefty dose but MDMA
it's 125 milligrams is a full dose and
so they were giving the wrong drug in
MDMA quantities
and that's why they knocked off a bunch
of these primates and that's why they
they claimed that they saw this
dopaminergic problems and so ever since
then and that's been 20 years ago now do
you think do you have speculation that
was sabotage somebody sabotaged it
somewhere I don't think it was from
research triangles do you think it's
accidental sabotage or do you think it I
don't I think that the researchers
um wouldn't have done that intentionally
but maybe somebody in the lab did it or
something but I do think that the
researchers were fundamentally
irresponsible to put the paper out
because they should have known
um that there was Prior primate studies
where dopamine hadn't been damaged the
the other thing is in the late 18
1980s early 1990s we were trying to talk
about yeah mdma's serotonergic
neurotoxicity and so I went to Georgia
cardi the same researcher that did the
primate study with the methamphetamine
instead and I said I want to buy you
some monkeys you've just done studies in
rats can you study this in in monkeys in
primates and he's he said he did and
again there was no evidence of um
overdoses or domain also this was before
brain scans came in
and so the most sophisticated way that
was available at the time to look at
what's going on in the brain was to do
spinal taps and to take spinal fluid and
look for metabolites of
neurotransmitters in the brain and I
felt like I could not
um
recommend uh try to get other people to
volunteer for it unless I did it myself
so I was I was the first one to get a
spinal tap and it was really hard but
the the imagery that I did and again
this is kind of this idea about
storytelling so the story I was telling
myself as this big needle is going into
my spine to try to draw out the spinal
fluid was that if a woman could give
birth to a child
I could at least give birth to my spinal
fluid
it was like way less painful much
shorter but I could do it and so the
imagery was I'm giving my birth to my
spinal fluid to these researchers so
that we can understand what's really
going on with MDMA and hopefully make it
into a medicine and it didn't hurt
terribly
and there was spinal headaches that you
get afterwards so a couple days
afterwards I had headaches but I felt
like I could
um enroll other people I can encourage
other people to do it so I was going to
new College in Sarasota Florida
which by the way DeSantis is now trying
to kill and has fired the president it's
the most
um it's the Honors College of the State
of Florida and it is why is he trying to
kill her
um it's just uh what he's doing to
public education I mean this was the
symbol of the most what he called the
most woke School in a bunch of
transgender people a bunch of
open-minded people
um it started as a private school in the
60s merged with the state when they ran
out of money so he fired the president
he stacked the Board of Trustees and
he's making he wants to turn it into a
conservative school he's doing it for
political purposes to try to show that
he's anti-woke and that he is um wanting
to he what's going on in public
education in Florida is is really
frightening
um
George Soros is actually interested in
trying to help out at new College
because George Soros actually even
though he's the boogeyman for a lot of
the right wing he funded the central
European University in Hungary as as
after communism and it was killed also
by Orban in Hungary so you go after
public education as a way to try to
control intellectual narratives but but
anyway I was at new College's school and
we were experimenting with MDMA and so I
got about 35 people or so to get spinal
taps not just from new college but from
from all over and um the spinal taps
showed that there was no problems with
dopamine it was there was a little bit
less serotonin metabolites but also
lower serotonin has been linked to
risk-taking behavior
and so taking drugs is risk taking
Behavior particularly when they're
heavily criminalized so it was not
evidence
that it was serotonin neurotoxicity from
MDMA but it cleared dopamine so these
researchers should never have ignored
their prior data they were just so
willing to
demonize MDMA to get more grant money